I don't know if I really contributed
that much in government I think i did
because ronald reagan came up with the
real breakthroughs on that but when i
was 47 years the Arms Control director
he needed somebody and a team to take
his concepts to take his vision and to
make it into a treaty and that was not
exactly Ronald Reagan strong point and I
had a team in the arms control agency
that worked very hard and we're very
competent and dealt a lot with the
Russians as we were going through to you
know make sure that the verification was
very good make sure that we understood
what kind of weapons were included in
what were not included make sure that we
could have procedures for implementing
this make their certainly we would check
up on it so in that way I could help him
I gave advice along the way some of
which she took in some of which he did
not take but all of what you would
listen to and he was very very opened in
that way and it was very good about
really asking people their opinion and
my experience of government and I was in
government for 12 years is that when
people were with the President of the
United States they were very reluctant
to speak the truth and it was a real
problem in the White House Ronald Reagan
was such a laid-back nice person that he
didn't mind if people told him frankly
what they thought him in mind if they
corrected him he would you know
sometimes say things because he didn't
know about the weapon systems and he
didn't know about the details of this or
even above the details and the big
points and if he said well mr. president
there's another way of looking at it
that's how I usually started the
sentence which means you're dead wrong
in a nice way but there's another way of
looking at it he would take that in he'd
say thank you very much that that's good
to know again and so he wasn't going out
and saying these things that were wrong
there so I i contributed some
on that I think in the teaching of the
Shakespeare there are real lessons in
Shakespeare this is not just a device to
you know do management and leadership
lessons of which you know the libraries
are full of these shelves on how to do
everything like that but Shakespeare
really hit at all and what we can do and
what we do do is that we uncork
Shakespeare we break it down into
bite-sized pieces we make it easy for
people who are scared of the word
Shakespeare and think oh my god i can't
understand thing you ever said and so we
can really open up we don't add to the
insights of shakespeare because no one
can do that they're so fantastic but we
can add to the access of Shakespeare and
number three is that the new programmer
here at the Aspen Institute what I can
contribute to that is to do something
that's kind of a bridge and that's what
was wonderful about the Aspen Institute
that Walter prep key when he started
this place 50 some years ago said that
there should be a cross fertilization of
fields and minds and that sometimes
happen but recently it hasn't but what
this program does is look at the arts
not in and of themselves because you
know they're wonderful lectures that the
music festival is wonderful lectures on
art you know the artist did this and
these mine was that and everything like
that that's not mine I'm doing what I'm
doing is building on that and saying
okay how does that art form help us
understand some issues or ideas and it's
a larger consideration of the Arts and
that's basically what we do in movies
and Shakespeare's it's an art form drama
okay how does that help us lead our life
better and there's lots of I mean North
Shakespeare thousands example but you
just need someone to help you that with
that bridge so we're trying to do that
not just in Shakespeare with removers
Shakespeare's but in the arts and ideas
program to take music for example Mahler
his personality what does it tell us
about creativity what does it tell us
about
the way the mind works then it's a nice
leap to Freud because Freud
psychoanalyze them what is left of Freud
today what what do we know about how we
think how we feel how our instincts were
and through Mahler and his relationship
with Freud we can understand ourselves
better